partout dans le monde plus de deux
millions de personnes sont désormais
atteinte du coc vide 19 près de 129
mille ans sont décédés mais plus de 500
2000 sont guéris les etats unis sont le
pays le plus touché au monde avec 610
milka et 26000 décès l'europe reste
fortement impacté avec un million de cas
et plus de 80 4000 décès l'espagne
enregistrent 177 mille 700 cas et 18
mille six cents morts en italie
l'épidémie était à l'origine de 160
2500k et 21000 décès ce soir en france
nous des comptes on sent 6206 cas
confirmés selon santé publique france
soit 2633 de plus qui hier depuis le
début de l'épidémie
soixante quatorze mille trente personnes
ont été atteintes par manas par la
maladie et ont dû être hospitalisés
selon les remontées 2240 établissements
de santé trente et un mille sept cent
soixante dix neuf personnes sont
actuellement hospitalisés pour une
infection kovy de 19 le nombre de
malades hospitalisés reste donc très
important en 24 heures 2415 nouveaux
malades ont été admis à l'hôpital
comme vous pouvez le voir sur le
graphique le solde présente pour la
première fois une baisse ce soir grâce
aux sorties qui sont nombreuses
nous avons 513 personnes hospitalisées
en moins par rapport à hier c'est donc
la première baisse il faut la saluer
tout en restant très prudents et en
entendant la suite de l'évolution en
particulier les prochains jours 6457
patients nécessitent des soins lourds de
réanimation un tiers de ces patients ont
moins de 60 ans et l'on dénombre 80 19
patients de moins
de 30 ans en réanimation au cours des
dernières 24 heures
284 nouveaux patients qu'ovide 19 ont
été admis en réanimation 7 plus qu'hier
cependant le solde reste négatif depuis
une semaine
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ce second
graphique aujourd'hui le solde est de
273 patients en moins une légère baisse
des besoins réanimation se confirme il
faut noter qu'il existe toujours de
fortes tensions dans certaines régions
dans les outre mer guadeloupe guyane
réunion martinique mayotte on relève 134
personnes hospitalisées dont 40 en
réanimation
au total depuis le début de l'épidémie
c'est près de trente et une 31 mille
personnes hospitalisées qui sont rentrés
à domicile sans compter les dizaines de
milliers de personnes guéries en ville
sans passage par l'hôpital et c'est une
bonne nouvelle
nous avons donc encore de nombreuses
hospitalisations et beaucoup de passages
en réanimation mais aussi de plus en
plus de patients qui quittent l'hôpital
et je m'en réjouis c'est très important
aussi pour soulager nos soignants qui
donne tellement de même mais vous le
voyez vous le constaterez visuellement
nous sommes bien face à un plateau à un
très haut plateau la surveillance
syndromique en population permet de
recenser de repérer l'activité en ville
hier les services d'urgence ont
accueilli 2167 passage pour suspicion de
co vide à la suite de cette prise en
charge 36 % des patients ont été
hospitalisés
cette proportion augmente avec l'âge et
3% des passages ont nécessité ensuite un
transfert en réanimation
sos médecins recense 548 intervention
hier en ville pour une suspicion de co
vide au cours de la journée ce qui
représente 10 % de l'activité totale et
d'activité est en baisse pour ce motif
le réseau des laboratoires au 14 avril
nous nous signale qu'il a passé le cap
des cent mille tests réalisés
le taux de positivité reste à 25% soit
24 1962 test positif
nous augmentons régulièrement vous le
savez nos capacités de test nous sommes
très attentifs à la situation des
personnes les plus vulnérables dans les
établissements sociaux et médico sociaux
au total depuis le début de l'épidémie
5340 établissements sociaux et médico
sociaux ont déclaré des cas 41 1657 cas
dont 14 1393 confirmés et 27 1264
possible c'est grâce à la déclaration de
tous les établissements et est la
remontée régulière d'informations que
nous pouvons suivre donc l'évolution de
l'épidémie au sein des établissements
pour personnes âgées et au sein de
l'établissement qui accueille différents
populations vulnérables en
établissements médico sociaux
en ce qui concerne la mortalité première
source la mortalité hospitalière
dix mille six cent quarante trois décès
sont à déplorer depuis le 1er mars 82 %
des décès surviennent soin des personnes
âgées de plus de 70 ans et on note on
note aussi 19 décès en outre-mer nous
déplorons 6524 décès en établissements
sociaux et médico sociaux rattachés au
co vie de 19 depuis le début de
l'épidémie le 1er mars
j'attire votre attention sur le fait
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une mortalité
observée en 24 heures
la hausse ce qui est observé ce soir est
liée à rattrapage de saisie des données
dues à des mises à jour et surtout à
l'issue de ce long week-end de trois
jours l'essentiel des décès observés en
ehpad 6339 et on note aussi 185 décès
dans les établissements médico-sociaux
nos nepad
depuis le 1er mars en additionnant les
décès survenus à l'hôpital et les décès
survenus en institution nous déplorons
17 milles 167 décès en france en lien
avec l'épidémie
vous le savez
l'insee surveille de très près les décès
toutes causes confondues qui je vous le
rappelle additionne les décès à
l'hôpital
les décès en institution et les décès
survenus à domicile il ne s'agit pas
seulement des décès liés aux copines
mais bien de tous les décès survenus
dans le pays
nous aurons des données précises après
étude de tous les certificats de décès
cette analyse prend du temps je vous
rappelle qu'il y à chaque mois de mars
en france entre 40000 et 60 mille décès
nous aurons des données exhaustive dans
plusieurs semaines
mais d'ores et déjà les certificats
électroniques de décès sont en cours
d'étude par les services de l'insee et
par l'inserm
ces données permettent de pouvoir
comparer les décès sur différentes
années et de mois à mois
ainsi nous pourrons parler de mortalité
ou de surmortalité toutes causes
confondues par rapport à l'attendu
notons ainsi une évolution de la
mortalité toutes causes confondues en
france avec un excès détecté depuis la
mi mars
à l'échelon national la mortalité
atteint un niveau d'excès exceptionnelle
en semaine 14 la semaine 14 et celle du
30 mars au 5 avril avec un excès de 57%
l'excès de décès par rapport à la
mortalité attendue commencent à
apparaître aussi en semaine 15 la
semaine du 6 au 12 avril à l'échelon
régional pour cette même semaine en
observe un excès de mortalité déjà dans
trois régions la région ile de france la
région grand est et la région bourgogne
franche comté et cet excès apparaît
aussi pour la semaine 15 dans 21
départements qui présentent un excès de
mortalité qui sont issus des mêmes
régions ile-de-france grand test
bourgogne franche comté ainsi que centre
val de loire vous le constater ce soir
la pandémie de kobe de 19 est toujours
active nous devons rester vigilants
maintenir l'application stricte des
gestes barrières être attentif à la
distanciation physique permanente d'un
mètre entre chaque personne à la
distanciation social avec la réduction
drastique des contacts quotidiens
il est indispensable de respecter le
confinement pour que nos efforts communs
portent leurs fruits continuent à porter
leurs fruits pour soulager le personnel
soignant éviter des drames humains et
sauver des vies vous le savez tous les
patients qui ont besoin d'un suivi de
leurs pathologies chroniques doivent
avoir accès aux soins dès maintenant
avec l'ensemble des professionnels dont
ils ont besoin le développement de la
télémédecine le développement du télé
suivi sont des réussites
ce suivi est nécessaire indispensable
pour éviter toutes des compensations de
la maladie chronique je tiens à vous
rappeler qu'il est indispensable de
poursuivre ses soins et le suivi des
maladies chroniques avec son médecin
traitant avec son médecin spécialiste
avec le service hospitalier qui vous
suit des circuits spécifiques de prise
en charge pour les malades de co vide
existe mais parallèlement des parcours
spécifiques permettent de prendre en
charge tous les patients non atteints
par la maladie afin qu'ils ne croisent
pas de patients malades
donc je vous encourage encore une fois à
consulter votre médecin traitant à
l'appeler à appeler votre service
hospitalier qui vous suit régulièrement
car vous avez besoin de ce suivi
si vous êtes atteint d'une maladie
chronique de la même façon si vous
pensez être atteint d'une maladie aiguë
si vous avez besoin d'un avis médical il
ne faut pas hésiter à appeler et puis
évidemment en cas d'urgence vitale
je vous rappelle le numéro 15
comme l'avaient annoncé les ministres
marlène schiappa et olivier véran
l'accès à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse médicamenteuse en ville a été
adapté pour permettre aux femmes de
pouvoir en bénéficier par
téléconsultation l'arrêté a été publié
ce matin des fiches d'information pour
les professionnels ont été diffusées
cela signifie concrètement que les
femmes qui le souhaitent et si leur état
de santé le permet pourront faire leur
première consultation d'informations
parts et des consultations mais aussi
récupérer les médicaments nécessaires à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
auprès de leur pharmacien
la prise de médicaments puis la
consultation de contrôle post ivg
pourront aussi être réalisés par
téléconsultation le délai de libérer
médicamenteuse en vie
a été allongé de 7 à 9 semaines
d'aménorrhée après avis de la haute
autorité de santé
je le rappelle les vg médicamenteuse à
ces termes se fait déjà dans certaines
indications
cet allongement être une des réponses
pour garantir un accès à libé j' avais
des protocoles déjà inscrits dans de
nombreuses recommandations
internationales je tiens à insister
lives et jette un droit que nous devons
garantir dans le contexte que nous
vivons je sais pouvoir compter sur tous
les professionnels engagés en ville
comme à l'hôpital pour que toute femme
en demande 10 vg y est
accès je tiens une nouvelle fois ce soir
à me joindre à vos remerciements
quotidien pour toutes les personnes
mobilisées dans la lutte sans merci
contre cette épidémie
je remercie évidemment tous les
professionnels de santé
je remercie tous ceux qui les aident au
quotidien par des actions de proximité
de solidarité de fraternité et je
remercie évidemment toutes celles et
tous ceux qui se sont mobilisés en
respectant jour après jour le
confinement et qu'ils poursuivront ce
confinement en restant chez eux pour
sauver des vies je vous remercie
une question de rmc après un mois de
confinement quel est le profil type des
nouveaux malades
est ce que ce sont des proches de
personnes récemment infectés des
travailleurs exemple des soignants
éboueurs ou caissiers nous n'avons pas
de profil type de nouveaux malades ne
savons pas de modification particulière
du profil de ces malades à l'admission
ce que je vous ai montré ce soir c'est
que le plateau est assez net il reste un
très haut plateau il y a encore beaucoup
d'admissions à l'hôpital il ya encore
beaucoup de consultations en ville
cette épidémie reste dynamique et elle
reste dynamique parce que nous avons
encore des contacts dans notre vie du
quotidien et donc ça concerne des
personnes qui ne sont pas soumises de
confinement et qui potentiellement se
comptent se contaminent lors des
contacts mais ça concerne aussi des
personnes qui sont soumises au
confinement et pour c'est pour ça que
quel que soit votre mode de vie quelle
que soit votre statut par rocco par
rapport au confinement
nous insistons et nous continuerons
d'insister dans les prochaines semaines
sur l'importance des mesures barrière
soit l'importance de l'addition station
physique n'est pas aussi naturel que ça
de rester vraiment à distance les uns
des autres
et puis de la distanciation social - il
y adeux contact - il ya deux
possibilités de transmission du virus
pour france 2 depuis l'annnonce du
dépistage généralisé dans les ehpad le 6
avril la rsi de france n'a pu tester les
résidents que dans 15 établissements
certains établissements dans lesquels il
ya eu des décès n'ont pas été jugés
prioritaires par la rs et donc pas testé
quels sont les critères qui permettent
de tester en établissement plutôt qu'un
autre alors tous les établissements sont
prioritaires c'est très clair nous avons
donné une priorité extrêmement forte à
tous les résidents des ehpad
évidemment quand on parle des résidents
des ehpad on parle aussi du personnel
des ehpad puisque des résidents étant
confiné
s'il y a eu des cas dans une dans une
aide dans un établissement il faut
évidemment testé le personnel et les
résidents
nous avons encouragé l'accès aux tests
dans l'ensemble des ehpad c'est un sujet
territoriale un sujet de proximité nous
avons demandé à toutes les ehpad de
bénéficier d'une ligne directe avec
l'hôpital de proximité
nous avons proposé à toutes les ehpad
d'avoir accès à une procédure de
dépistage
évidemment ce dépistage n'est pas
complètement le même n'est pas
symétrique
selon qu'il s'agit d'un membre du
personnel ou d'un résident un membre du
personnel peut se rendre dans un
laboratoire et éviter de rentrer dans
l'ehpad un résident bien sûr doit
bénéficier d'un dépistage dans sa
chambre et au plus près de son lieu de
vie donc nous organisons tout cela c'est
un un effort très important qui est fait
notamment par les collectivités locales
qui est fait par les agences régionales
de santé dans l'ensemble des
départements
l'idée étant que tous tes pattes qui le
demandent puissent avoir accès à ce
dépistage en particulier s'il ya un
foyer actif pour que nous connaissions
très vite l'état de diffusion du virus
dans l'établissement afin de séparer au
mieux les le secteur de personnes
contaminées par le virus et le secteur à
protéger une question de diaspora news
après être guéri du coc vide et ont une
mini est immunisée pardon où peut-on
retombées malade une seconde fois alors
nous disposons de quelques données
scientifiques
comme vous le savez ce virus a émergé il
ya trois mois donc nous n'avons pas
encore beaucoup de recul sur son
évolution et sur la réponse de l'homme à
l'infection
en général quand on fait une infection
par le corona virus et c'est démontrer
par des études en france sur les malades
et plus grave on développe une immunité
dans les semaines qui suivent deux
semaines ou trois semaines après
l'infection et cette immunité semble
protectrice et semble pérenne
après question c'est qu'il faudrait
suivre encore pendant des mois une
personne qui ont été contaminées pour
s'assurer que ces anticorps persiste il
peut y avoir des formes semble-t-il
mineurs peut-être des formes orl ou des
formes extrêmement bénigne qui ne des
petits ne débouche pas sur une immunité
et qui expliquerait à ce moment là que
des personnes puissent être affectés à
deux reprises ce n'est pas du tout
évident en tout cas ce n'est pas
confirmé par la littérature
il peut y avoir aussi des sujets de
réponse aux deux tests on a remarqué que
dans certains pays on pouvait être
positif avec un test négatif le
lendemain et puis de nouveau positif que
surlendemain donc tout ça mérite
peut-être plus de données scientifiques
pour rassurer l'ensemble des français
sur ce que veut dire ce test négatif on
se teste à nouveau positif pour
hospimedia
les établissements sociaux et médico
sociaux sont invités à remonter le
nombre de professionnels touchés par le
cos vite 19
combien de cas ont été signalés à ce
jour alors nous avons un recueil qui est
en cours de consolidation par santé
publique france nous aurons des chiffres
qui seront rendus plus grand des publics
par santé publique france avec la
répartition des personnels qui sont
positifs en ehpad avec nous ce qui nous
avons énormément de personnel en ehpad
et en institution plusieurs centaines de
milliers qui sont aussi des françaises
et des français comme les autres et donc
qu'ils ont le même risque d'être infecté
par le virus parce que ils travaillent
et qu'ils sont donc au service des
personnes les plus fragiles et des plus
âgés d'entre nous
donc nous aurons ces chiffres rendus
publics par santé publique france de
façon hebdomadaire avec cette priorité
donnée à la surveillance de la situation
dans les ehpad en france pour mehdi site
que pensez vous du discours du
professeur raoult qui a déclaré que
l'épidémie de covile 19 étaient en train
de disparaître
quand je vois que le professeur raoul tu
s'exprimait sur les données de
surveillance dont ils disposent
ali a chu c'est à dire à marseille
et effectivement nous notons que
plusieurs secteurs feront de foot us
international que plusieurs départements
que plusieurs régions ont une
circulation virale relativement faible
par rapport à d'autres
on a noté depuis plusieurs semaines que
des régions étaient extrêmement sous
tension c'était le cas du grand test
c'était le cas de l'île de france il ya
eu moins de circulation dans certaines
régions nous aurons des données
d'ailleurs de séroprévalence dans les
prochains jours
et donc je crois que professeur raoul
décrivait les résultats dont il qu'il
analyse dans son laboratoire
une autre question pour mehdi site
l'italie a décidé de rouvrir les écoles
en septembre pourquoi la france at-elle
opté pour une stratégie différente
n'est ce pas risqué que je n'ai pas à
commenter les décisions du gouvernement
italien
une dernière question de mehdi site
avez vous prévu des mesures ou des
stocks spéciaux comme les masques et les
gants en cas de deuxième vague alors je
crois que c'est important de dire aux
français que nous faisons aujourd'hui le
maximum pour bénéficier d'un nombre de
d'équipements de protection suffisant
pour protéger nos soignants vous le
savez nous avons passé beaucoup de
commandes nous avons encourager la
production nationale de masques en
particulier de masques chirurgicaux de
masques p2 nous importons aussi des
quantités très importantes de masques de
l'étranger et donc ce stock 1 permettent
de répondre évidemment aux besoins
actuels et aux éventuels besoins
ultérieurs
donc nous nous mettons en situation de
gérer en permanence un risque de
diffusion virale et de protégé en
permanence nos soigneurs une question
pour la paix m
des masques ffp2 sont ils bien
distribués dans les établissements et
services de psychiatrie
car même si les professionnels ne font
pas de gestes invasifs en tant que tel
les masques chirurgicaux ne suffisent
pas forcément quand on travaille avec
des patients qui peuvent être agité ou
imprévisible alors nous avons demandé
aux sociétés savantes ainsi qu'au haut
conseil de santé publique de définir
l'usagé des masses pour les soignants il
a été très clairement dit à la fois par
la société française d'hygiène
hospitalière par le haut conseil de
santé publique par l'organisation
mondiale de la santé que pour un
soignant qui est exposé à un malade le
masque chirurgical est suffisant les
masques ffp2 qui est un masque
particulier
réservée à des actes invasifs en
particulier en réanimation
parce qu'il ya un risque d'aérosols et
donc tout cela était parfaitement cadré
tous savaient parfaitement rappelé par
l'ensemble des sociétés savantes pour
tf1 lci
pourquoi le gouvernement refuse de
donner aux médecins étrangers des
fonctions médicales alors que le corps
médical demain des moyens
supplémentaires
alors c'est un c'est un dossier qui est
suivi de très près par la direction
générale de l'offre de soins qui gère
les professionnels de santé
et vous savez que nous avons déjà donné
accès en particulier aux médecins à
diplôme européen et donc les pour les
médecins dits pas du cder le médecin
praticien ayant un diplôme étranger hors
union européenne
il y a une démarche est en cours avec la
direction générale de l'offre de soins
une deuxième question pour tf1 lci le
professeur delfraissy a émis des
réserves concernant concernant
l'immunité des personnes déjà
contaminées par le cos vite 19
quelle est la position de la dgs il n'y
a pas de position de la dgs par rapport
à la position du professeur delfraissy
qu'elle profère des pressings ne fait
que rapporter ce que ce que je décris
c'est à dire en pratique
l'absence encore de connaissances
solides sur l'immunité acquise après
l'infection
donc il il ne fait que traduire l'état
actuel des connaissances scientifiques
il n'y a pas encore beaucoup de
connaissances sur des dizaines de
milliers de malades avérés qui sont
devenus ensuite quelques semaines plus
tard séropositifs et pour lequel on
saurait dire que ces anticorps son
protecteur et que ces anticorps vont les
protégés pendant des mois puisque
aujourd'hui aucun malade n'a d'anticorps
depuis plus que deux mois ou trois mois
même les malades chinois qui ont été
pris en charge au mois de janvier au
mois de février on n'est finalement qu'à
peine deux mois plus tard donc il va
falloir du recul et parfois les données
médicales mettent du temps et données
scientifiques met du temps à être
consolidés même si effectivement ces
questions sont parfaitement légitimes
une autre question pour tf1 lci
est ce qu'il y a des informations à
communiquer sur le charles de gaulle et
le nombre de personnes contaminées
je ne dispose pas de ces informations je
crois que le ministère les armes et fait
le maximum pour prendre en charge ces
personnels question pour rfi vous avez
recommandé aux personnes fragiles de
rester confinés
11 mai mais à quoi cela peut-il servir
si leur conjoint reprend le travail ou
si leurs enfants en bas âge est
incapable d'observer les mesures
barrières à la crèche ou à l'école
alors effectivement nous allons devoir
élaborer avec le gouvernement avec
l'ensemble des secteurs concernés des
bonnes pratiques pour protéger au mieux
les personnes vulnérables à l'issue du
confinement
vous savez que nous parlons de personnes
âgées nous parlons de personnes qui ont
des pathologies chroniques qui ont des
fragilités particulière et évidemment il
faudra tenir compte de leur
environnement puisque nous aurons
effectivement des situations
individuelles particulière et il faudra
je le dis aussi continuer tous nos
gestes barrières nos mesures de
distanciation physique nos maisons de
distanciation sociale si une personne
reste confiné pour une raison x ou y
en raison de son âge d'une pathologie il
faudra qu'on soit très attentifs quand
on va l'avoir à domicile il y aura le
sujet des ehpad aussi un qui va falloir
traiter puisque c'est un sujet
évidemment très douloureux pour beaucoup
de français
cette difficulté de ne pas pouvoir aller
rendre visite à ses grands parents mais
je pense qu'il va falloir que nous
adoptions tous dans les semaines et dans
les mois qui viennent ces mesures
barrières ces gestes assez peu naturel
de distanciation physique et social pour
protéger en permanence les personnes les
plus vulnérables real media à partir du
11 mai toujours
envisagez vous de mettre en place un
dispositif de prise de température des
personnes entrant dans un lieu public
comme cela se fait dans certaines
régions en chine
alors c'est une question qui est
compliqué je pense que la vraie réponse
française elle est la même depuis le
début les français ont plus tendance à
faire confiance à la professionnelle de
santé et donc à avoir un avis médical a
demandé un test rapidement je pense que
c'est l'engagement du gouvernement que
de proposer un test et le président de
la république la demande et donc ça sera
vraiment ce que nous ferons nous d'avoir
accès rapidement à un test quand on
pense qu'on est infecté par le courant
des virus et donc je pense que c'est une
réponse plus satisfaisante que
d'imaginer que parce qu'on n'a pas sonné
lors du passage du portique on n'est pas
affectée donc je pense que voilà on est
plus sur un mur une prise en charge dans
le lien de confiance qui existe entre
les français et leur
leur professionnel de santé et leur
médecin traitant en particulier je pense
que la personne qui se pose une question
après le 11 mai comme vous dites sur son
éventuelle contamination par le grenat
virus elle a le réflexe le bon réflexe
d'appeler son médecin traitant et de
demander quelle est la procédure pour
avoir le test france 2 pour l'émission
envoyé spécial vous avait indiqué la
semaine dernière que grâce au
confinement mis en place depuis le 16
mars une vie a été sauvée en moyenne
toutes les 8 minutes
at on une idée de nombreux devis qui
auraient pu être sauvées si nous avions
annulés le premier tour des municipales
le 15 mars
non je pense que la question n'est pas
forcément pertinente dans le sens où
aujourd'hui on voit que le confinement
est efficace que ce confinement a permis
à notre système de santé de tenir à nos
hôpitaux de tenir à l'ensemble des
réanimations d'accepter les malades les
plus graves dans des bonnes conditions
il ya eu d'évacuation sanitaire qui se
sont très bien passées et professionnels
de santé ont été héroïques il ya eu des
volontaires à centaines et donc je crois
que les français ont parfaitement
compris l'impact du confinement
et puis il ya il ya un enjeu qui n'est
pas du tout une question négligeable
c'est que on le voit dans le monde
entier et on aura maintenant des
capacités de comparaison sur le
confinement le confinement à un vrai
enjeu c'est la réduction des contacts
lorsque le virus commence à circuler
activement et donc les modélisateurs qui
ont donné ces délais les chiffres que je
vous ai donné ont parfaitement démontré
qu'un confinement trop précoce n'a aucun
impact est qu un confinement trop
tardivement n'a pas non plus donc la
décision de mise en place d'un
confinement avec délicate mais elle est
vraiment lié à la présence du virus à
une circulation active du virus et je
pense que les français par leur respect
très très élevés par leur adhésion très
forte à ce confinement ont permis
d'éviter des drames ont permis de sauver
des vies et je pense que ils ne se
rendent pas compte même s'ils ont
l'impression d'être passif à la maison
combien ils sont actifs dans la lutte
contre l'épidémie pour l' agence
italienne en deçà attend justement fixé
des paramètres pour décider de la date
et des modalités du déconfinement et at
on fait de la concertation avec les pays
voisins
au sujet de la fermeture des frontières
de l'espace schengen oui il ya beaucoup
de discussions au sein de l'europe et
c'est le président d'un public
évidemment mènent ces discussions il est
très attentif à la situation européenne
il y a effectivement cette situation
notamment en espagne en italie qui est
proche de celle que nous vivons la
grande bretagne et qui est aussi un pays
voisin a subi une vague importante et
donc aussi apprend de l'impact du
confinement et il ya beaucoup d'échangés
évidemment entre les équipes
scientifiques les réanimateurs et les
médecins au sein de l'union européenne
même au niveau international donc nous
tenons compte des expériences des autres
nous nous coordonnons nous apprenons
chacun
pas à pas de ce qu'il se passe à
l'extérieur tout ce qui est retour
d'expérience et partager je crois qu'il
ya énormément t'échange au niveau
scientifique au niveau politique parce
que tous ensemble nous devons apprendre
à lutter au mieux contre cette épidémie
une question de ses news est ce qu'il y
a beaucoup de fumeurs parmi les malades
du coït dix neuf sont ils plus touchés
par le virus
alors c'est une question complexe
d'abord parce que le statut fumeurs
n'est pas forcément enregistré dans le
dossier médical en particulier en
réanimation il ya les données
contradictoires sur la prévalence du
tabagisme en milieu hospitalier en
milieu de ville ce qu'on sait aussi
c'est que les gros fumeurs les
insuffisants respiratoires sont plus
fragiles et font des formes plus sévères
donc quand on a une atteinte
respiratoire ça a été bien démontré il
ya des formes plus sévères
donc voilà où nous en sommes et ça
nécessite évidemment d étude
épidémiologique plus poussée
c'était la dernière question merci à
vous
il